this is a paternoster lift there are
only a few working examples of these
left in the world like this one at the
Arts Tower of Sheffield University it is
an open Elevator Shaft with a series of
connected carriages going round and
round and round in it on a constant Loop
one side goes up and one side goes down
and you just get in and out this is a 20
story building by the way so this is a
long chain a pster can carry more
passengers than a regular lift although
obviously there's a little bit more
danger of trips falls and injuries this
particular lift has a lot of extra
safety features to stop people getting
injured too but for that reason and
because they're inaccessible to anyone
who can't walk or is carrying big things
or can't walk well and because there
aren't many companies in the world that
build or refurbish them anymore they
aren't installed and those that are left
tend to get ripped out of old buildings
and replace but Sheffield kept theirs
and they also have some more standard
lifts just in case now I can't stay in
this lift as it goes over the top thank
you Chris uh I'd unbalance the whole
thing and I would risk it getting shut
down and the fire brigade coming in and
turfing me out but what I can do is
leave this little GoPro camera in to
show you what it's like to go over the
top
so I'll see you in a couple of minutes
here we
go see you in a
minute
I'm looking forward to seeing the
footage from this
yeah